that was like a dream come true
I have the tiger okay well as you know
my name is oh honey did look liquor here
my name is Alexander Pope I'm super
super excited to be here really honored
that I was invited to come all the way
from frozen Norway to visit beautiful
Melbourne to tell you this story now
it's a scary story and like the best
scary stories it's all true mostly now
as you know this is called outbreak
index
- SW - 9 a 4 C 4 B 4 B 4 7 7 8 e 7 D 1 C
a 6 1 9 EI EI f 5 AC 1 BB jeaious
the year is 2016 and in the corner of a
functional low charmless openoffice
Alexander sits at a desk staring
intently at the screen a phone range in
the background momentarily disrupting
the early morning stillness hey wow you
can import analytics data into can I use
and it looks like we already have over
50% serviceworker support Alexander it's
still considered experimental the
specification has not yet stabilized nah
that's all they were talking about at
Google i/o serviceworker is the best
thing since ajax that's already huge in
India be not the first by whom the new
are tried nor yet the last to lay the
old aside the following morning in a
cramped meeting room
Alexander enthusiastic these sketches on
a wall-mounted whiteboard this is great
it's basically a proxy server in your
browser you just call navigator
serviceworker
register with a path to your script it
returns a promise so that's cool
[Music]
Alexander I hope you are aware that the
service worker lifecycle has non-trivial
there are many opportunities for error
no no no no this is the web if something
is broken you fix it and ship it
continuous delivery for the win at
Google IO they recommend you just change
something the service worker will be
invalidated and reinstalled eventually
anyway
within 24 hours at least fools rush in
where angels fear to tread
days later Alexander hurries to clean up
commits while rebasing a git merge in
time for release the desk is littered
with disposable coffee cups embed unique
acid leaves add feature flag use cache
first strategy add cache expiry logic
cache all API JSON data add app shell
pad online offline Status Messages
remotely log errors alexander haven't
you forgotten something
what about testing
testing serviceworkers hard so many
Global's and an installation lifecycle
things are working fine locally and
anyway it's progressive enhancement the
most positive men are the most credulous
[Music]
several weeks pass in the quiet of a
darkened living room alexander anxiously
scans air logs notification alerts
pierce the silence type air undefined is
not a function not a function how could
i at serviceworker global scope dot o
not be a function what the hell is going
on I don't get it things have been
running smoothly for weeks the only
change here is some refactoring how
could cache ad all be undefined it works
fine on my machine versions of Chrome
prior to 46 did not ship with cache
value at all among other differences the
specification is still unstable as you
are well aware shut up you are not
helping lead to focus while I revert
these changes one week later
back at the office Alexander puzzles
over the latest error logs
that's what weird it's been almost a
week since I ever heard of those changes
but there are still lots of errors it
shouldn't take that long to upgrade it's
just not possible
the logs say otherwise there have been
more than 2,000 errors reported in the
last 24 hours alone
more weeks pass visibly tired and
distraught
Alexander slumps over his computer at
the dinner table a baby cries in the
background this is starting to freak me
out I don't understand how they can
still be so many errors and it looks
like it looks like they're coming from
inside the house Alexander don't be
ridiculous
the errors are clearly not coming from
inside the house is it me but inside me
my affected with these errors no
Alexander you are not infected it would
appear that for a small number of
clients index - yes W - 984 c43 be forty
four seven seven eighty 71 CA six 198 AF
v AC 1d bjs has been permanently
installed what permanently you can never
be upgraded like some kind of dead song
that is correct
you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up big time
I told you it was a scary story
[Music]
there's something strangely compelling
about a disaster story sometimes the
disaster is an act of God other times
it's man-made but the best of them share
this in common
the central characters are faced with
difficult sometimes impossible moral
dilemmas as viewers we ask ourselves how
we would behave in similar circumstances
could we handle the pressure would we
make the same choices would we do the
right thing now some of my favorite
disaster stories are about epidemics or
disease outbreaks that threaten humanity
I think of not as living dead 28 days
later 12 monkeys or children of men and
many others now many of these stories
and in fact the whole zombie genre were
inspired by this book I am Legend by
Richard Matheson now the book has been
adapted at least three times for the big
screen but my favorite version is the
Omega Man from 1971 starring Charlton
Heston I love it because it's just so
70s and Charlton Heston he just can't
stop delivering these cheesy one-liners
no matter what happens to him he has no
place here here's the stink of oil the
electrical circuitry about him is
obsolete you are discarded you are the
refuse of the past you're full of crap
now the antagonists in this version are
more human than the vampires and the
zombies of the other adaptations and I
like that this cult of albino mutants
spend all their time raging against the
science and technology that they blame
for their fate now most zombie stories
of course they don't plan on turning
people into zombies it just sort of
happens by accident and usually it's
because technology goes a little out of
control now as I struggled against my
own mob of out-of-control service
workers I began to worry about this rig
of technological back
now as web developers were constantly
tempted to throw in more and more
technology at the problem but if we're
not careful we risk pissing off our
users making things that are slow or
annoying or insecure just full of bugs
really risks alienating the people we're
trying to make happy now
I'm sure some of you are dying to find
out what happened some of your oops
dying to see some code other of you are
probably dying after last night's party
but before we go any further with the
rest of the story we need to take look
at serviceworker what makes it so
special and what makes it so especially
dangerous first some history in 2010 as
part of html5
we got the application cache API which
was a high level API for declaring which
resources should be cached for offline
use by 2014 however it was clear that
the app cache API wasn't low-level
enough to be useful so work began on a
new spec called serviceworker that would
enable more granular control over
caching of resources among other things
a year later at the beginning of 2015
chrome 40 and opera 27 became the first
browsers released with basic
serviceworker support now in the summer
of 2015 we were introduced to the
concept of progressive Web Apps and
shortly after came Firefox 44 and
Samsung internet 4 in 2016 and later
that same year at Google i/o in May
serviceworker and progressive web apps
were put on center stage
finally in 2018 the application cache
API is being deprecated and
serviceworker is due to land in all
major browsers with the next releases of
Safari and edge very soon I hope
but what is a serviceworker anyway a
serviceworker is a script running in a
separate background process that can
intercept and modify all Network
requests made by a web application now
serviceworker as the name suggests is a
type of worker similar to a web worker
in that it doesn't have Dom Ajax or
local storage it does however have
postmessage for communicating with pages
and other workers fetch for contacting
the network and indexdb for storage a
serviceworker is a kind of proxy server
that responds to network requests by
returning response objects from the
network from cache or from dynamically
generated content now in theory this
means that a web application should be
able to function without a network at
all and in practice having full control
over your cache should also improve
startup application startup performance
to make this possible serviceworker has
access to a new api including cache API
for storing Network request response
pairs and new a new clients API for
managing connected windows and tabs and
web workers now since serviceworker runs
in a separate process independent of the
browser so it runs outside of the
browser process it can do more work than
just proxying network requests it can
also respond to push events by receiving
and displaying push notifications and
sync events by processing pending
network operations that were made while
the network was offline because they can
control several clients at the same time
while operating in the background
service workers need to be installed on
the device now upgrading remotely
installed software while it's running
without breaking anything is really
really hard
serviceworker is not the
we are used to but it's probably the web
we need of course difficult things are
rarely simple and as you'd expect
serviceworker is complex by design to
get from zero to up and running takes a
multi-step lifecycle that includes
registration installation sometimes
waiting and finally activation before
your serviceworker can get ready to do
its work now the first step of the
serviceworker life cycle is registration
which is initiated by the web page when
you call navigator serviceworker
register with a path to your file and
once the serviceworker is eventually up
and running it's going to be able to
control all pages that fall under its
scope the scope is determined by where
that serviceworker file is served from
and it can be restricted but not
expanded so in practice this means that
a serviceworker can only control pages
that live at the same or lower level in
the directory hierarchy so that's
important this brings us to our first
bug busting tip don't call register
while the page is loading on first visit
it's too late for the serviceworker to
start controlling the page so there's no
point trying to load it before the page
itself is loaded it's only going to slow
things down so you should wait for the
window load event or some other signal
before calling register tip number two
is don't rename your serviceworker file
this is extremely important and it's
also a little bit hard to get your head
around but once it's been successfully
installed its eventually going to need
to be updated
now if the HTML file that registered the
serviceworker is cached which is quite
common it's going to be impossible for
you to install a new service worker with
a different name so you can avoid this
kind of chicken and egg problem by
making sure you never tried to rename
your serviceworker file it should always
be a static file name
now of course if the file name is static
if it's never gonna change and the
browser was always going to fetch files
through the browser cache before going
to the network you're gonna have to make
sure you set the proper cache control
headers to prevent the browser from
caching is outdated versions of your
serviceworker file now as a precaution
to avoid accidentally installing a
serviceworker for days or weeks or
months the browser is automatically
going to bypass the cache if the file is
older than 24 hours regardless of what
you set of course waiting 24 hours to
fix a bug is a painful experience so do
your future self a favor and make sure
you set a low expiring now after the
script has been successfully registered
the install event is going to be
triggered and the serviceworker is going
to enter the installation face this is
generally the best opportunity to begin
pre-caching your assets it's also a good
opportunity to talk about promises now
the service work API takes promise used
to new extremes so using async await can
make things much more legible and
potentially less error-prone now
although all browsers only recently
began supporting async all browsers that
run serviceworker also can handle
converting async code to use generators
and promises so you can use babel with
the async two generator plugin to do
this transformation with very little
overhead you should also make sure that
pre cached assets can be downloaded
because passing a promise to the await
until the event wait until method is
going to delay serviceworker
installation until all those fetches are
resolved however if it's rejected if
even one asset does not download the new
serviceworker is going to be thrown away
so since cache a doll is often the
easiest way to bulk fetch and add things
to the cache any request is going to
cause the serviceworker
to prevent being installed so in this
sense pre-cached assets should be
considered hard dependencies so just
beware now there's already an older
version installed and running
controlling clients the Service Worker
is they're gonna enter what they call
the waiting phase until all the clients
have been disconnected
calling skip waiting is going to force
the new Service Worker to be activated
regardless and it's gonna but forcing
activation after an update can break all
these existing connected clients if the
new Service Worker behaves right
differently than the old one you should
probably avoid calling skip waiting
after this major gene and consider
prompting the user to trigger a manual
refresh instead so really easy all you
need to do is listen for a serviceworker
event update prompt the user to force
the serviceworker to skip waiting and
then reload the page when it becomes
active is that really easy it only took
three slides so much easier than calling
skip waiting but much safer now when
it's finally safe to begin controlling
your clients the activate event is going
to be triggered and you can clean up old
caches before control is finally passed
to the new serviceworker be careful
though don't accidentally remove caches
that may be used by other applications
so the cache API is origin based and it
doesn't restrict access based on the
scope that you used to register the
serviceworker so you should prefix your
caches with an application name if you
plan on running multiple service workers
on under the same domain
now once the serviceworker is actively
controlling clients any network requests
are going to trigger the fetch event
handler and the serviceworker is going
to be able to return a response based on
URL headers cookies resource type
network conditions whatever criteria you
now handling the response is going to
allow the service worker to perform
runtime caching but you should always
check the ok property of the response
object returned from fetch before you
add it to your cache because HTTP
response codes don't cause the fetch
promise to reject so you check for 404
and 500 for example another thing to
avoid is storing global State outside of
the event handlers in your serviceworker
file the service workers once they're
started they run that code but service
workers are also stopped and started
many times over their lifetime that's to
preserve battery and other resources on
the device and that global state is
going to be destroyed at unexpected
times so I'm sure all that seems quite
straightforward right now I bet you're
wondering what the deal was with those
zombies quite simply it was part
ignorant part stupidity and part mystery
in my defense I don't think it was equal
parts but you can be the judge it turns
out that versions of chrome before 46
did not support cache at all so any
client missing that API should have
caused the promised return to the
install event to reject for the syntax
error undefined is not a function now
unfortunately a catch was also added to
the promise chain in order to report
install errors but the error was never
thrown further up the chain and the
serviceworker was installed instead of
being thrown away and that explains how
some clients became infected with a
broken serviceworker and based on the
number of errors reported you can see
that most of them were cleared of
they're infected serviceworker but it's
still mystery as to why or how a small
number were cursed and were never able
to upgrade to a newer version it was
fortunate that this only affected a
small
older devices but it's totally
unfortunate that this is not the only
way you could break your serviceworker
let's be honest cache and validation is
heart upgrading software is also hard
and promises art kind of hard also
naming things is super hard
serviceworker has all of this and more
so what do you do in the event of
disaster if quitting your job is not an
option you might want to buy some time
by deploying a suicide service worker
that unregistered itself deletes all
caches and force refreshes all connected
clients if you like your job you can
make sure you don't ship a broken
service worker in the first place by
testing before you deploy of course
testing service workers is not trivial
but you can run unit tests in a mock
environment with tools like SW test end
and you can even run a single set of
tests on both the command line and in
the browser with SW tester now I'm not
sure I totally trust the organization
behind these libraries I mean Pope
industries doesn't really sound like
even a real company but there isn't
really much else out there today to
choose from so it's definitely better
than nothing lastly if you don't want or
need to get your hands dirty with the
details you can use one of several tools
to help you generate a service worker
and managed runtime caching but you
should always test if you can even if
the details were lost on you the hope of
at least been able to convince you that
service worker should be approached with
respect and handled with care
serviceworker is awesome and it lets us
do things on the web we have never been
able to do before
but it's kind of awesome in the way that
a chainsaw is awesome it's really
powerful and a really easy way to lose a
hand
under a foot or maybe a few toes but
don't be afraid a lot of people use
chainsaws everyday without spilling
blood they take precautions they dress
for the job and they read the
instructions even disaster stories can
have happy endings now that I know more
now that I have some tools for testing
I'm not afraid to get back into the lab
and I hope everyone here isn't either
because the web really is much better
with serviceworker thank you very much I
hope you enjoy the rest of the day good
boy Alexandre get off this stage
[Applause]
you